الانفجارات الكبيره والقصف العنيف يحدث في
محيط مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البله
حيث الغارات الاسرائيليه لم تتوقف خلال
الساعات الماضيه بل كانت قويه وعنيفه جدا
والقذائف المدفعيه حيث سقطت بالقرب من
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح وسط
قطاع غزه حيث القصف المدفعي تركز خلال
الوقت القريب الماضي في منطقه شرق دير
البلح بالاضافه الى منطقه الزوايده في
محيط مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح في
هذه الاثناء على ما يبدو تقوم القوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
المحافظه الوسطى بشكل كامل وعام في هذه
الاوقات وهناك قصف مدفعي ايضا مازال
متواصل يسمع في المناطق الشرقيه لدير بلح
حيث اغارت ايضا قبل ما يقارب من الساعه من
الان الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على هذه المنطقه المحاذيه
لشارع صلاح الدين بعده صواريخ من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه الاف 16 في هذه
المنطقه ايضا كانت قد تواجدت هنا خلال
الساعات الماضيه عدد من اليات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ولكن عادت موضعها في المناطق
الخلفيه التي تشهد في منطقه محيط المصدر
اشتباكات عنيفه ومواجهات ضاريه ما بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه والقوات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة